also want to invite you to participate
in the david pakman show
subreddit discussions you can find that
at davidpakman.com
slash reddit more than 30 000 of our
viewers and listeners
have already subscribed a couple of
posts i want to
briefly discuss that i spotted on the
subreddit this morning
one user uh said backlash
to new mask recommendations show why the
left
are bad at politics arguing the cdc
changed mass guidelines to say
you can wear them indoors and there has
been surprisingly a lot of backlash to
this
from our own side let me be straight
this is a huge political win for joe
biden his agenda is back to normal
and the quicker we get back to normal
the better he looks and in terms
dems and the left as a whole if he were
a republican president
every single republican would be
shouting through the roof stops of the
success of this
and how we are basically out of the
pandemic instead our own side seems to
be actively hampering our political
agenda
by questioning the science of the
decision and some cities and states are
keeping mass mandates
in effect regardless of the science so i
think that this is a really really good
point and i'm going to do a commentary
later
where i'm going to talk about the the
mask forever stuff um
i i won't preempt that because i'm going
to get into it i think this is a really
astute commentary
which is uh some of the reaction when
the cdc said
vaccinated people don't really have to
wear masks anywhere because the vaccines
are so effective and the spread is cut
so dramatically and the risk is just so
low
a better reaction would be it's
incredible how quickly joe
biden got us to this point the left
could have united
and made this unilaterally a win for joe
biden look
biden did covet stimulus and he asked
people to wear masks for 100 days
and all this different stuff and
vaccination and now look at what the cdc
is able to say
unfortunately i think that some on the
left misplayed it by saying this is
crazy even though we've been following
the cdc all along
we're going to keep mask mandates we're
going to do all this different stuff
that frames it as not the win that it
really should be considered and this is
a separate question from whether
individuals
could should or might choose to keep
wearing masks personally
which i think is perfectly fine and i'm
going to address later i think that's a
very astute commentary about a missed
opportunity by the left excellent post
also a number of posts including this
one about joe rogan's comments
that quote straight white men are being
silenced by quote
woke culture i did a big rant about this
yesterday during a live stream where i
talked about
the um the predecessors
to so-called woke culture which is not a
term i use but it's sort of a
a follow-on of michel foucault's
post-modernist
analysis of literature which has turned
into critical theory and a bunch of
other things which lead us to
every narrative every narrative has to
be equally valued when i really don't
think that that's a good idea
and there are some extremes which maybe
joe rogan is alluding to but big picture
joe rogan's comments about woke culture
and uh people aren't going to be able to
go outside anymore because in the past
some have been imprisoned and straight
white men won't be able to speak
it goes cartoonishly too far i ranted
about it for almost 15 minutes yesterday
on a live stream we might pull that and
make it a standalone clip
but i i do think that joe rogan goes too
far
here in his comments and i think most of
my audience tends to agree with that
but join the discussion yourself on the
subreddit
by going to davidpakman.com slash
r-e-d-d-i-t
it's free i'm selling you nothing other
than a free good time
okay uh check it out one of our sponsors
is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my vincero
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman